رعبا امريكيا حقيقيا. فكيف
سيجابه الامريكان التحالفات
على الصين وحلفائها حين حاولت ضم
اليابان لحلف الناتو. منطقة
الامريكية وبمحاولة لرد
الاعتبار. هنا واشنطن تحاول الرد
الاتصالات المالية العالمية بين
البنوك سويفت فهذا سيؤدي الى
كانت كل من الصين وايران والهند
ودول اخرى ستتحرر عاجلا او اجلا
المتحدة الامريكية عن عرش
الصدارة. وليس ذلك وحسب فاذا
والطرق. وخطوط انابيب الغاز التي
ستكون مرتبطة بروسيا الى غاية
مبادرة الصين طريق الحرير الجديد
البالغة الف مليار دولار عن اي
معا باي باي امريكا. مهلا.
تعالوا لنرتب هذه الاوراق. ايران
لتخلو المنطقة قريبا من اي قوة
خارج هذا الحلف المعلن. لنقولها
القبلات الحارة ها هي ايران تزيد
طين واشنطن بلة. حيث اعلنت طهران
المنطقة بما في ذلك السعودية
والامارات وقطر والبحرين والعراق
الامريكي. مرت الايام وقوات
واشنطن تسرح وتمرح متناسية صفعة
برعاية الجراح الصيني. لتنجح
العملية السياسية وينتج عنها
لنجاح الناتو الاطلسي لا تزال
غائبة عن الشرق الاوسط. ايران
السعودية اخذت طهران خطوة معاكسة
لم تتوقعها واشنطن. فالتقى
دول الخليج ومعها مصر والاردن
والعراق. اضافة الى اسرائيل. لكن
لمنع ايران من الحصول على سلاح
نووي. والحلم الاخر صنع ناتو
قوقعتها الهادئة لتفتح اعينها
الضيقة وتتحدث بلهجة شديدة في
بداية الضربات الجوية في الساعات
الاولى لاي صراع. بكين خرجت من
سيدن الاسترالية. ليشير التقرير
الى ان ترسانة الاسلحة الهائلة
العام الفين وسبعة وعشرين. الصين
هي ايضا بصدد ان تكون القوة
الاقتصادية العالمية الاولى خلال
هذا العقد. مسيحة الولايات
والصعود الصيني والصحوة
الايرانية اخر. في خطوات اثارت
عندما ربط بايدن سياسته باضافة
تل ابيب بهذا الحلف يعلم بان
الشرق الاوسط لن ينضم لحلف يضم
الكيان. وكما يقول العرب اراد ان
يكحلها فاعماها. وتلك الجهود
الضخمة التي سعت بها واشنطن
الايرانيون مع السعوديين لعلاج
هذا الصدع السياسي والعسكري
الصلح الايراني السعودي. وما
ستترتب عليه من عواقب ستؤدي لقطع
هو الحل? ايران والسعودية. لترد
روسيا فلتعلنا تحالفكما وعن حلف
نتحدث. وللقصة بقية. بكين تتقدم
وواشنطن تتألم. ظلت امريكا وصية
الكتلة الاقتصادية لحوالي سبعين
دولة خارج سيطرة الولايات
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ بين
المصالح الامريكية من جانب
والهدف ليس اخراج امريكا من
المنطقة. بل الخروج من البوتقة
الاسطول الخامس تيم هوكينز ان
التحالف الذي اعلنت ايران
ويتحدى العقل. ليضيف هوكينز ان
ايران هي المسئول الاول عن عدم
الاستقرار الاقليمي. وتريد تشكيل
تحالف امني بحري لحماية المياه
التي تهددها على حد قوله. اذا
اردت ان تأمن ثعلب فلتسلمه
الصين القاضية. اصاب واشنطن
وحلفائها الاوروبيين الرعب بسبب
ارقام نتحدث يا لها من ميزانية
ضخمة. لكن هذا الطريق سيربط
من الدولار الامريكي باعتباره
عملة احتياطية عالمية ومن جمعية
حلفائها رغبت ورهبت. هددت وحذرت.
كل ذلك ضمن استراتيجية جديدة.
دول من منطقة المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ وكل ذلك حتى لا تدخل
هبوط حاد لقيمة الدولار وانهيار
ما لي في الولايات المتحدة
عربي لتحتوي سياستها التوسعية في
المنطقة. على ان يشمل هذا الحلف
واثنين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
يشد رحاله للمرة الاولى نحو
الشرق الاوسط ممسكا احلامه بيديه
والهدف جمع موافقات دولية عربية
العالميتان لشعوب كل البلدان.
ويجب الا نسمح لهذا التاريخ
المأساوي بان يعيد نفسه. هي
رسالة صينية بالا تراجع ولا
ازمة اخرى كالتي تشهدها اوكران
نعم. ابناء شيبينج يقولونها
الشمال الاطلسي. وهذا الامر لن
يؤدي سوى الى اغراق منطقة اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ في زوبعة من
النزاعات والصراعات. انتم تريدون
العسكرية الجديدة. بما يشمل
الامن السيبراني والذكاء
التي تمتلكها بكين تهدد القواعد
الاساسية التي تمتلكها الولايات
في منطقة المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ. الامر لم ينتهي عند ذلك
واشنطن تفوقها في منطقة المحيط
الهادئ. وهذا ليس كلامنا. انما
واصبحت تتحدى الولايات المتحدة
في مجالات عسكرية عديدة. لتفقد
الصين. وان كان ذلك بكسر
القوانين الدولية للاسلحة. لا
هو تقرير جديد اصدره مركز
الدراسات الامريكية في جامعة
وتحالف اوكوس خير دليل. لكن ذلك
لا يكفي. فعقدت واشنطن شراكات مع
من ابناء العم سام. الاجابة
واضحة. فكل ذلك جاء من اجل حصار
المتحدة وحلفاؤها. وان مثل هذه
يمكن اعتبارها بلا فائدة مع
مفاتيح القن لانه سيكون المسؤول
ان نقص من القن دجاجة. ضربة
محذرة للسعودية منطقتنا هي
الهدف. هم يستهدف شرق اسيا ولكن
اعتزامها تشكيله مع السعودية
ودول خليجية اخرى امر غير منطقي
لتنفض امريكا غبار الخيبة
ويعلنها المتحدث باسم قيادة
حليفة للصين وروسيا وهي اليوم
للسعودية وباقي الدول العربية.
بها امريكا وصدعت رؤوسنا بها.
اما ان لنا ان نتحد لنواجه
المتحدة الامريكية. مبادرته
ببناء خطوط السكك الحديدية
عن تشكيل تحالف عسكري مشترك
للبحرية الايرانية مع دول
بتحالفاتكم المسموحة. ايران تدخل
على الخط. منتصف عام الفين
ويكررونها. يجب الا ننسى الكوارث
الخطيرة التي سببتها الحربان
احتاجت المنطقة للقوة فالصين
موجودة وليس هناك داع للتداخل
وجوه الامريكان. قائلة انتم
تخططون لنسخة اسيوية من حلف
يمكن تكرار الناتو. الصين كانت
قوة صاعدة نعم. لا صعدت بالفعل
الاصطناعي والصواريخ التي تفوق
سرعة الصوت. فما كل هذا السخاء
طوت صفحة الماضي وبدلا عن زيادة
حدة التوترات مع المملكة العربية
مشاركتها لصالح بريطانيا. مع
تعاون مشترك في مجال التكنولوجيا
اتفاق تاريخي مفاده ان المنطقة
ليست بحاجة لوصاية امريكية. وان
تحالف مع الغرب في منطقتنا
الخاصة. ولن نسمح لكم بتلويثها
الايادي الامريكية من المياه
الدولية. ايران ومع قليل من
والعين الاخرة تتوجه صوب ايران.
لا تدعوهم يقترب من حدودكم.
اوراق اللعب ليتم ترتيبها من
جديد. الاصابع الايرانية تشير
المتناحرة. الحكمة الصينية تصيب
هدفها بدقة. امريكا تعلن عن
عسكري جديد. امريكا تضرب على
خديها لتقول لبريطانيا فلتقرصيني
كي افيق من هذا الكابوس. نعم عن
تحالف ايران والسعودية العسكري
المحلية والاتجاه نحو قمة
العالم. ورحلة الالف ميل تبدأ
بالهبوب. واشنطن جيشها من
افغانستان بعد ان انسحبت من
العراق بينما تبقي على قلة من
جنودها في سوريا. لكن في المقابل
الجديدة?
ما الذي يخطط له الامريكان? اولا
سحبوا قواتهم ثم انشأوا تحالفا
استراتيجي مع كل من استراليا
وبريطانيا تحت مسمى تحالف اوكوس.
الممنوع بل هي سياسة العالم
الجديدة وهي التي فرضت ونثرت
بخطوة. اسابيع قليلة بعد
الانسحاب الامريكي المفاجئ من
افغانستان والذي اثار موجة
انتقادات من الحلفاء
لن يمروا. وبعيون ضيقة ونظرات
حادة العين الاولى ترمق السعودية
فالسياسة الامريكية تعيش على شرب
الدم وبيع الاسلحة للدول
انشاء ناتو اسيوي والهدف مضايقة
الصين والنيل من الاعداء. اذا ما
والهدف دائما وابدا مجاب التنين
الاحمر الصيني. صعود صيني مرعب
جديدا. اليس امرا مريبا? نعم.
واشنطن كثفت تحركاتها. زادت من
اجبر امريكا على اقامة تحالفات
امنية وعسكرية في نطاق ضيق
امريكا في مواجهة مباشرة مع
الصين. وبالرغم من ان الاعلان عن
التحالف لم يحمل اي اشارة صريحة
الى الصين الا ان التحالف الذي
على اسيا شرقها وغربها وشمالها
مع الجنوب. بدأت الريح العاتية
دول اسيا لم تضيع وقتها عبثا.
فالصين تبني نفسها منذ عقود.
ومساعيها هي ان تصبح القوة
الاقتصادية والعسكرية المهيمنة
المتقدمة التي تعمل بالطاقة
النووية. وهي المرة الثانية التي
تشارك فيها الولايات المتحدة
تقنيات النووية المتطورة بعد
يمتد من الولايات المتحدة الى
المحيط الهادئ مرورا باوروبا لم
بل ان امريكا اعلنت تزويد
استراليا باسطول من الغواصات
يكن من الصعب فهم ان عنوانه
الرئيسي هو مواجهة صعود الصين
الاستراتيجيين للولايات المتحدة
لتعلن الاخيرة عن تحالف امني
التحديات نحن نتحدث عن ايران
والسعودية. هو ليس مسلسل العشق
بالحضن يا ابن عمي فلننسى الماضي
ولنحرق ورقة العداء التي ارهقتنا